In today's video,
we're going to see
if we can make paper burn
hot enough to liquefy metal.
[Music]
This is paper.
Paper was invented in China in
approximately the year 105 CE.
It's usual for a lot of things.
We use it for writing,
printing, drawing, folding,
and occasionally,
although it's not
a very common fuel,
we do use it for burning.
It's made from wood cellulose,
and so, it's
a flammable product.
The temperature which
paper burns is famously
451 degrees Fahrenheit,
and that's not very warm
as fires go.
In fact, it's about
as cool as you can get.
But today, we wanted
to put something to a test.
We wanted to see
if we could take paper,
which can burn fairly cool,
and make it hot
enough to melt metal.
We've got a couple different
ways we're going to try that.
Here's the basic idea.
We're going to see
if we can use just paper
as a fuel source to get hot
enough to melt our metal.
First thing we're going to do,
it's kind of cheating honestly.
The metal we're going
to use is gallium,
and gallium melts
at about 85 degrees Fahrenheit,
which is well below the 451
Fahrenheit of paper burning.
So, I would be very surprised
if we can't get the gallium
to burn a little bit.
But we want to go
a step above that,
and move to aluminum.
I've got an aluminum can,
a ball of aluminum foil,
and some aluminum wire,
and we want to see
if we can get any
of these to melt.
And to give ourselves a really
good chance rather than
just having printer paper,
we got a couple rolls
of paper as well.
It's the same stuff that's made
from the tree cellulose.
It's just brown,
and it hasn't been cleaned
and bleached to be white,
like the printer paper,
and conveniently,
comes in this little roll.
So I'm thinking,
we might be able
to make some sort
of rocket stove style burner
out of this paper,
and hopefully, we can get
enough heat consistently
to actually melt down
and liquefy our metal.
Now, the first thing
that we're going
to try is our gallium.
I'm going to put that
in this stainless steel cup,
which has fairly thin edges
and bottom to it.
So it should transfer
the heat pretty nicely.
We're just gonna make a little
fire using this printer paper,
and we're going to see if that's
enough to melt down our gallium.
There's definitely heat
coming off of the paper,
but it's not staying
in one place very well.
So it's sort of hard to
concentrate our gallium over it.
Although I think we are,
even with that issue,
starting to melt our metal.
There you go.
There's some liquid
metal right there.
So, as proof of concept,
can burning paper get hot
enough to liquefy metal?
Well, the quick answer is yes,
depending on how
your paper setup,
and of course,
what metal you're using.
It's pretty easy
when you use a metal
that melts at under a
hundred degrees Fahrenheit,
which is not very common.
That's not going
to be a big problem.
If you've got gallium,
and you need to melt it,
this is going to be
pretty easy to melt.
You can just leave it
outside on a hot day,
and it's going to liquefy.
So, we want to take
this up a notch,
and we want to see
if we can get it
to melt aluminum,
and that's why we've got
those rolls of paper.
I've got a couple ideas
for how we might be able
to make that work.
I've got this whole
roll of paper.
I'm not going to try
and use a whole thing.
I'm going to cut off a section
that's about 1 foot long.
That's what we're going to use
for our first little test
furnace we're going to set up.
I've now got this roll of paper,
and this has a lot more fuel
than those 5 or 6 sheets
of printer paper.
But in addition to that,
it's all held together.
So hopefully, all of the heat
will be concentrated.
My thought is that
if I light the inside on fire,
it will just keep burning up
from the inside to the outside.
And so, all of our heat will be
contained in one little spot.
But even that,
I don't think it's going
to be quite enough
so I want to make
another modification.
When you're making fire,
you need a few different things.
You need fuel,
and that's gonna be the paper,
but you also need oxygen.
So my thought is
that will drill a hole down
near the bottom of it
that it can draw
oxygen in through,
and if that doesn't seem
like it's enough,
I've also got
this little bike pump,
and I've actually used this as
a form of cheap bellows before.
It's pretty simple.
It's got a little
nozzle on the front.
You just push on the back,
and it blows the concentrated
blast of air out.
So here's the other thing.
We need to have good airflow.
If we set the can right on top,
it might just stop all the air
from going anywhere.
So I might be able to hold
the can at its side,
but then it's likely to roll off
with all the air flow,
and I need two hands
to work the pump.
So instead of using
the can on this one,
we might just go
with the aluminum wire.
That would be pretty easy
to just hook a piece
of wire in there, and see
if it melts from the heat.
Okay, we've got our roll of
paper with our oxygen vent hole.
These two bricks were just
using to hold everything steady
because you know,
I might bump it or something
while I'm trying
to pump air into it,
and I have just a sheet
of aluminum foil underneath
just kind of want to keep track
of what all is lost here.
I expect a lot of paper ash
will fall out of that.
But I'm also curious,
if this does melts to the point
that it liquefies,
I kind of want to catch it
as it falls down,
lands on that piece of aluminum.
So we're just going to get
this burning a little bit.
See if it's self-sustaining
at all, and if not,
start adding some oxygen.
[Music]
Well, right away,
I'm going to say
that it's smoldering,
but we're not seeing much fire,
so I'm gonna see if I can add
some good old-fashioned O2
will make a difference.
[Music]
It kind of burns on its own,
but not super well.
I think it does need
the additional oxygen
from the pump so we're going
to keep using that.
Let's put our wire in, and see
if we can get it to melt.
Oh, it just broke.
Oh, and there's actually some
little drips down there too.
Okay.
This is why I put
the aluminum down there.
Right there, that
piece fell off.
We've also got some little spots
down on the aluminum
that look like they
have dripped down.
Well, those...
This little spot right here?
[Music]
Yeah, that's what I wanted.
That's some little bits
of aluminum drips here.
One actually fused
onto the aluminum foil
to the point that I
can't take it off.
It just tears.
So, as a proof of concept,
melting aluminum,
that worked okay.
So now, I'm going
to try scaling this up,
and I had that bigger
roll of paper,
and I've got a plan
for how I don't have
to use the little bike
pump the whole time,
which I hope works
because that gets tiring.
Much much bigger roll of paper.
That is fuel for days.
So, same general idea.
We're going to have a hole down
at the bottom where we can have
some just airflow,
and we're going to make
it a bigger hole,
and it's actually going
to be big enough for this piece
of metal conduit.
Well, I think this
is made of steel, but
if it's made of aluminum, then,
we're going to see something
interesting as it melts.
But we're going to fit this in,
and then this is going
to be attached on the other side
to an air pump.
Right about over that nozzle,
we use some tape
to hold it in place,
and that's just sit
off to the side,
feeding are into our furnace,
which should hopefully just
burn, burn, burn beautifully.
It's a great size.
This aluminum can for example
just barely fits in.
It's got a little bit
of space on the sides.
I think we're also going to try
and drill a couple of holes up
near the top that
this steel rod can fit into.
That way, it you just
act as a support,
it can hold our can up
where we want it
without it just falling
right down to the bottom,
and that way,
I think we'll get a lot
of good air flow, and hopefully,
melt this can down
to nothing really quickly.
Okay.
We've got our big roll,
got the steel bar
to hold our can up,
got our hose attached
to our pump.
Just going to try and get
this started burning.
Let's see what happens
if we just had
a good flow of oxygen.
See how much heat we
can get out of this.
[Music]
Feel like I should also say,
I cut our metal conduit
a little bit shorter
just to get the airflow
more directly there,
and it cut very easily
to the point that I suspect
this is also aluminum.
So we may end up just melting
through our conduit
at some point.
Let's see.
So I've noticed something
as I'm trying to melt this can.
When it's in place,
the airflow is
a little bit restricted,
and I've had it go out.
So if it goes out again,
I'm actually going
to take the can out,
and let it burn
for a bit to sort of open
up the top of our furnace.
I really want good flow of air
because it's the oxygen
that we need.
[Music]
Ooh, that's deformed.
Down here at the bottom,
we've started melting
our aluminum foil.
I just put that there as
sort of a catching spot,
but it started to melt
it quite a bit.
[Music]
We're getting a lot more fire
blasting out the bottom,
and I don't know if that's just
because of the shape.
Ooh, wow.
Well, the can
is definitely losing
structural integrity here.
But I want to try
flipping this upside down,
and it might just be that
because this is closer
to the air vent,
it's getting more heat.
So, we're going
to try just flipping
this whole thing upside down.
[Music]
I would say that's hot
enough to liquefy metal.
That's gone.
We need to scale
this up a little bit.
Oh, and we have started
melting our pipe as well.
That's good.
[Music]
That's some little
Minecraft figures
that we're going
to call me and Cali.
I think we're going to try
and make a mold of one of these.
So we've got some molding sand.
We're going to try and press one
of these down into that,
and make a copy
of it in our aluminum
if enough aluminum melts.
Okay, I like that.
We're going to call that good.
See about pouring
aluminum into that.
It's a decent pool
of aluminum now.
[Music]
So this is interesting.
We had this burning
for a good while,
probably 45 minutes.
Just getting all
that metal heated up,
melted down, turning
into a liquid,
and it did liquefy it.
It liquefied it quite well.
I pulled the steel rod out.
That was just in
there to help the crucible stay
in just the right position,
add just the right
amount of airflow.
The steel rod was in there just
to help hold that crucible
in just the right spot,
and have a good amount
of air flow.
But that steel rod
was red hot to the point
where I think you probably
could have even used that heat
to do some basic forging.
Like I think if I'd taken
a hammer to that,
it would have been soft enough
that I could manipulate it.
So just using paper and oxygen,
we are able to get
it hot enough
to heat up a steel bar to the point
that you could work it
as blacksmithing techniques.
[Music]
Well, I'd say it's not a 100%
perfectly faithful reproduction
of our little
Calli Minecraft figure,
but it's the basic shape.
That worked all right,
and the flaw here was
not the melting of the aluminum.
The flaw here was
my molding technique,
where I just pressed the figure
down into the sand instead of
the careful like layering
you're supposed to do,
like through a sieve.
With this kind
of ultra fine sand,
it can pick up a ton of detail.
But it also is
a little bit sticky,
and you're supposed to use
like some baby powder or
something to separate the two.
Overall though,
paper melting metal?
Absolutely.
It may burn it
451 degrees Fahrenheit,
but it can clearly get
way way hotter than that.
Guys, that's not all.
We've always got more
for you to see.
The box at the top is going
to take you to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box shows you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And if you hit this bomb
here in the middle,
that will subscribe
to the channel.
That way, you never miss
out on a cool video.
And of course,
don't forget to ring
the bell so you get
the notification about it.
We'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.